la parole est présenté aux ministres des
affaires étrangères de la fédération de
russie 6e lavrov je vous remercie cher
président
géré députés de la douma d'état je veux
remercier pour cette occasion de tenir
mon discours devant vous dans le cadre
de cette heure hommes gouvernementales
les liens étroits entre le service
diplomatique et
le parlement sont continues nonobstant
la situation ap de mlle g compliqué au
mois de décembre j'ai rencontré que vous
le savez vos collègues du conseil de
fédération et aujourd'hui je me prépare
à au dialogue mesurer pour des questions
de la politique étrangère pour nous au
ministère des affaires étrangères et les
est surtout important de sentir les
priorités du corps des
législateurs nos apprécions votre
implication
les députés représentent les intérêts de
tous les milieux de la population et
comprennent leurs intérêts la mission
primordiale du ministère des affaires
étrangères c'est toujours de créer des
conditions extérieures a
sécurisé pour assurer le développement
continu du pays
c'est mission de se confier au niveau
doctrinal dans le concept de sécurité
nationale
1 signé par le président de dépasser et
qui a trouvé son reflet dans le concept
de politique étrangère qui sera achevé
d'ici quelques temps aujourd'hui dans le
concept actuel
le président a plusieurs fois pris
parole il a mis tous les accents aux
fondamentaux lors des collèges élargie
de notre ministère de celui de ministère
de défense durant ses conférences de
presse
la haine internationale connaît des
modifications profondes qui sont pas
toujours positives assez j'ose le dire
le système dans fièvre je dirais
les états de l'occident historiques ne
sont pas prêts à accepter les réalités
du monde multipolaire qui est en train
de se former qu'il doit être plus juste
plus démocratique et que le monde avec
la domination d'un seul état les
représentants de l'occident menée par
les états unis font des efforts à
s'opposer au courant objectif de
l'histoire afin de s'assurer des
privilèges unilatérale sans compter les
intérêts d'autrui du tout même sans
prendre en considération les intérêts
légitimes de deux collègues washington
impose sa propre vision de l'ordre
international en l'appelant la nécessité
de créer et de respecter l'ordre basée à
des règles dans le cadre de ce concept
l'occident s'approprie le droit de
labourer les droits dans toutes sortes
de domaines et en ignorant complètement
le principe de multilatéralisme qui a
répondu au possible de
l'organisation des nations unies en
sapant le droit international et les
décès dans qui essaient de mener à leur
politique indépendante est avant tout
notre pays la chine
ont su force
à n'obtenir à l'aide de toutes sortes
d'instruments au mal propre compte des
sanctions la diabolisation dans les
médias des provocations des services
secrets et j'en passe ces derniers temps
les états unis et leurs alliés européens
qui ont oublié le aux bases de la
diplomatie double les efforts pour la
dissuasion de notre pays à part les
sanctions illégales unilatérale il un
fonds
renforcer la pression militaire et
politique il suffit de regarder les
manoeuvres militaires de plus en plus
provocative à ou de voir comment qui est
vrai est de plus en plus initiés
dans l' arbitre de le temps en recevant
des de l'armement
dans ce concept contexte on entend de
plus en plus souvent les exigences
cynique d'arrêter la réalisation des
exercices militaires sur notre propre
territoire ce qui est notre droit
fondamental
les double poids double mesures
n'ont jamais été aussi fort
la situation est contradictoire
aux principes de la sécurité égale et
qu'on vous savez récemment nous avons
envoyé aux états unis et aux membres de
le temps le projet de contrats entre la
russie et les etats unis ce projet deux
contrats étaient ensuite publiées et
hansi que en accord
visant à sur les mesures de sécurité
entre la russie et le temps les
documents aux fourneaux ensemble et vise
à assurer pour notre pays des garanties
fiables et juridiquement contraignante
de la sécurité lüthi janvier à genève
nous avons un négocier notre initiative
avec les américains deux jours après le
12 11 janvier avec les membres de l'otan
et encore un jour plus tard au dans le
cadre d'une session de laisser notre
représentant a aussi porté l'attention
des participants à ces documents mais
ces documents je le répète encore une
fois ont été envoyés aux états unis et
aux membres de le temps le vent 1er
janvier à la demande des collègues
américains j'ai eu des pourparlers à ce
sujet avec le secrétaire d'état des
états unis anthony blinken qui
affirmait et nous espérons que ces
affirmations hausses seront respectés
que les états unis dont environ 7 durant
cette semaine les réponses écrites à
fixant la position des états unis est le
réponse à nos exigences selon cette
réponse que nous attendons cette semaine
nous allons au préparer ensemble avec
nos collègues d'autres ministères des
propositions aux ministres et aux
précédents pour des spas ultérieure
faire traîner dans le temps notre
initiative en multipliant des
discussions
comptez moins aux comptes que témoignons
aujourd'hui dans le 6e ou par voie d
appel à persistant de l'union européenne
à se trouver la place dans ces
discussions nos laisserons pas faire
dans le cas où nous n'avons pas une
réponse constructive et le temps
persiste à amener sans cap
agressif ou moscou comme le président
d'un déjà dirhams entreprises à prendre
des mesures appropriées de toute façon
tout le monde doit se baser à ce que la
sécurité de la russie de ses citoyen
c'est une priorité absolue qui doit être
assuré a en tout état de choses
[Applaudissements]
en réalisant la politique extérieure et
multisectorielle et c'est le terme que
nous utilisons à partir du début des
années 2000 nous ne fixons pas nos
efforts uniquement à eau à la direction
occidentale douaud ces derniers temps on
reçoit des menaces et des défis
d'autant plus que le monde est depuis
longtemps depuis longtemps un unipolaire
ni a centré sur les etats-unis
aujourd'hui la majorité des pays
partagent nos approches fondamentales
qui renoncent aux la dictature
idéologique de l'occident l'humanité et
des lignes plus adulte
sacrifier les intérêts fondamental pour
faire la besogne pour les
confrères de l'occident on ne veut plus
on en a parlé en entreprise que le
centre de la politique internationale
est dorénavant dans la zone euro et
éthiques la russie
est
parmi les plus intéressés à
l'aménagement de qualité de ces
territoires
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'union
eurasiatique le travail est coordonnée
avec les projets de la communauté des
états indépendants dans les domaines
appropriés
notamment dans les questions de libre de
libéralisation du commerce on a connu du
succès considérable de développement de
l'état comme en russie biélorussie c'est
le travail qui est réalisé
quotidiennement nous renforçons notre
coopération avec les avec nos alliés de
pc
dans le contexte des perspectives assez
floue développements de la situation en
afghanistan à la
l'efficacité de des troupes de au ps et
dans le kazakh semaine suite à des
attaques massives contre l'état kazakh
ont
démontré d'une façon fiable
l'amour tu es et les capacités de cette
organisation en bon exemple des
relations entre les états
à l'époque moderne
représentée par la coopération russo
chinoises pour de multiples vecteurs
nous avons su progresser plus que les
membres des alliances militaires nous
apportons une attention particulière à
notre partenaire partenariat avec l'inde
ainsi que tu avec la majorité des
partenaires dans l'asie pacifique y
compris avec des états de 5 qui
connaissent un développement
considérable
à l'initiative du président du président
poutine et les ont informés en
partenariat eurasiatique nous le voyons
comment on contours
de développement en humanitaires
économiques et un sens plus large
on y voit une base matérielle pour la
construction de l'architecturé
eurasiatique de sécurité elle est
important que les portes pour ce
partenariat que nous proposons en forme
et sont ouvertes pour tous les pays de
notre continent eurasiatique
la coopération avec les pays de
l'afrique connaît réussie en
développement considérable ensemble avec
nos amis africains nous travaillons à
préparer le deuxième sommet russie
afrique a prévu pour l'année en cours
nous renforçons notre coopération avec
les états de l'amérique latine que qui
sont considérés par donc en centre
indépendant
sérieux dans monde un multi polaire
ayant de grandes perspectives
économiques chers collègues la russie
est l'un des majeurs guéron de l
architecture
de monde le membre permanent du conseil
de sécurité qui rentrent pas apporté une
contribution permanente dans la cause de
la stabilité à stratégique pour dialogue
des questions clés sont prisées pour par
la déclaration de monsieur le président
poutine pour le tenu des réunions des
membres perse permanent du constituent
de conseil de sécurité de l'onu le 3
janvier les 5,1 puissances nucléaires
ont adopté une déclaration commune pour
l'interdiction de la course aux
armements
visant à prévenir à la guerre nucléaire
à celle document qui est écrit à notre
initiative qui a encore une fois
souligné notre volonté a assuré en
dialogue à équivalent visant à assurer
l'équilibré juste équilibre des intérêts
parmi les as priorité aux on trouve la
mission d'assurer la sécurité en fanfare
nationale et cybernétique y compris par
le voix de
rédiger un convention
internationale de la lutte avec la
criminalité dans le domaine on travaille
dans le contexte bilatéral avec nos
partenaires y compris avec les
américains noah participant de façon
active dans l'activité de d'autres
structures le gérant un brick c'est
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai la coop et à l'interaction dans
le cadre de ces organisations renforce
la confiance mutuelle s'est de même que
nous considérons le
développement de la coopération dans le
format tripartite russie inde et chine
qui reste d'opportunités pour tous les
trois participants nos contribuant de
façon active à la régulation
pacifique des situations de crise dans
différentes régions du monde au karabakh
la syrie la libye l'afghanistan le
conflit arabo israélien
la situation maintenant ce que rennes où
le nucléaire iranien ces efforts
contribuent à l'assainissement comment
de la situation du monde
reconfirme à l'autorité de notre pays en
tant que partenaire fiable et prévisible
à l'international
je perds leurs invités sur la situation
aux halles est de l'ukraine notre
position est intacte ce n'est qu'en
respectant
pas par pas l'ensemble des mesures de
minsk en leur intégrité et en respectant
l'ordre
spécifié sur le document qui a été
approuvé par le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu étant devenu partie intégrante du
droit international le gage du succès le
seul c'est la création d'un dialogue
direct entre les parties du conflit kiev
donetsk est lougansk nos aplomb sans
cesse les etats-unis la france
l'allemagne et autres collègues
occidentaux ayant l'influencent sur les
régimes de qui est 20 à le forcer à
respecter les accords de minsk nous
allons poursuivre notre position rigide
d'interdire les tentatives de d'accuser
la russie pour
la réalisation de ce conflit et ne
permettront pas à faire du nom une
partie de conflit
nous travaillons à d'autres vecteurs de
la politique étrangère la priorité
absolue de la protection des droits et
des intérêts légitimes de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger le travail à
contribuer à la cohésion du monde russe
est toujours réalisée nous allons
[Musique]
poursuivre notre politique à lézan a
assuré l'accompagnement diplomatiques et
des projets d'investissement avec la
participation russe à l'étranger et
évidemment nous apportons une han
attention particulière à la promotion de
la langue russe et de la culture russe
nous voyons à quattre la nécessité de
lutter contre les falsifications de
l'histoire nous faisons bloc à toutes
les tentatives
de
falsifier l'histoire ensemble avec la
majorité des membres de la communauté
internationale ce qui est confirmé par
les votes
[Musique]
à l'onu
dans le contexte de l'interdiction de
les réalisations du facisme nous
poursuivons soutenir la participation de
notre pays dans les efforts
internationaux
visant à combattre la cornée virus est
en général dans le domaine de la
coopération
dans le cadre de l'organisation mondiale
de santé
évidemment nous allons poursuivre de
toutes nos forces le dialogue des
civilisations y compris en utilisant les
capacités de la diplomatie parlementaire
diplomatie
sociale pour conclure je dois dire que
les missions qui nous sont confiées par
le président sont envergure et pour
l'atteinte de ces objectifs et pour le
renforcement de nos positions à
l'international nous sommes intéressés à
renforcer la coopération quotidienne
avec la demande et un
de l'assemblée fédérale et nous allons
poursuivre notre activité à soutenir les
liens 1 avec les groupes de militants je
vous remercie de votre attention merci
beaucoup cercles sergei prenez votre
place s'il vous plaît jaakola maintenant
donne la parole
le président du comité et ensuite on
prépare la parole tenue messieurs
slutsky merci
s'il vous plaît oleg c'est à vous la
parole
je lave sergei et chers collègues notre
comme été il est connu
fell estimations des ministères d argent
sa part des outils du contrôle
parlementaire on as lease le suivi des
lois basique pour les ministères les
arrêter et les demandes parlementaire
comment les projets de loi sont préparés
notre comité a fait aussi un travail
similaire lors de l'étude et de la
préparation de cette heure
gouvernementales ou maintenant nous
pourrions faire part de l'estimation de
du respect des as parlementaire
ensuite s'il ya des recettes de
l'activité ajouté ensuite il ya des
remarques de la chambre de compte
maintenant je propose de dire
franchement qu'aujourd'hui l'heure
gouvernementale d'un fait partie de la
logique de ces estimations parce
qu'aujourd'hui la demande et a plus
souvent que les autres
aient défini sa position est publique 1
sur un grand périmètre de problèmes des
grandes paires et m